Welcome to Chillin 101. We hope this
video helps.
In this video, I will show how to
program Dodge Charger key fob. Easy
method. Begin with two working keys and
the new fob in hand. Then sit in the
driver's seat and close all doors.
Insert the working key and cycle the
ignition three times without starting.
Then remove the key and quickly press
any button on the new fob until the
locks cycle. If needed, repeat the cycle
once more to confirm programming is
complete.
Start by inserting the working key and
cycling the ignition three times, ending
with the key in the off position and
door is closed. Press any button on the
new fob until you hear the door lock
cycle. That indicates the fob learned
successfully. If locks do not cycle,
repeat the ignition cycle and press the
fob again. Finish by testing lock,
unlock, trunk, and panic to confirm
every feature works as expected with the
new fob. If the new fob fails to
program, first replace its battery and
try the sequence again while keeping all
doors closed. Double check that the dome
light is off and that you use the
working key correctly when cycling the
ignition. If problems persist, verify
compatibility with your charger model
and consider trying another known
working key or consulting a locksmith to
avoid unnecessary dealer fees and ensure
proper security features remain intact.
Thanks for watching.